Oh, hold on. Let's see. Wait, do we have another Platiner allegation?
What is this? A second woman says Graham Platner knew the Nazi
origins of his toten cough tattoo, contradicting his claim that
he only learned of it meaning its meaning last fall. She also
alleges he cheated on his fiance and described the tattoo as
a reminder that the US will was the evil bad guy. New York Post.
Oh, well, the New York Post. Well, if the New York Post said
it,
see, this doesn't make any sense to me at all. Right. People
say like this, people will come out with stories like this and
it's like I found a good tweet about it earlier today. Hold on,
let me go to my bookmarks. I think I bookmarked this tweet when
nobody was looking at Graham Platner.
This is what he said. This is what he talked like.
God damn it. No. Germany to undertook a concerted effort at the
national level specifically backed in numerous documents backed
up in numerous documents to wipe the population within its borders
from the faces of the earth. all the with the support of the
German people who had energetically supported the rampant anti-semitism.
Like he literally is anti-
fascist in his own posts and right
talks about being like how hard it is for LGBTQ people in the
Marines. Like this is who he is when he thinks nobody's looking.
He is not a Nazi. It's just not possible to call this guy Nazi.
I'm sorry. You could call him a lot of things. You can call him
stupid. You call him reckless. You can call him so many different
things. A cheater. Can't call him a Nazi. It doesn't make any
sense. Sorry. It's never going to work. It's never going to stick.
The article. Okay, let's check this out real quick before we
go in.
Graham [clears throat] Platner
cheated on fiance and brag Nazi tattoo was reminder. US was the
evil bad guy. Lover tells Post.
Main Senate nominee Graham Platner kept his hideous Nazi tattoo
to remind himself the US was the bad guy overseas. Evil bad guy
overseas. According to an ex-girlfriend with whom he cheated
on his fiance in 2021.
wait. He was dating his current girlfriend in 2021. Interesting.
The leftwing streamer who spoke to the post is the second woman
to say Platner knew about the fascist origin of his totem cop
tattoo. Despite his claims that he didn't realize it was a Third
Reich symbol until last fall. Her assertions were backed up by
texts reviewed by the post that she had sent to her mom in September
2025 in which she blasted him for his Nazi tattoo small and claims
that he tarnished her reputation by using her to step outside
out on his
I would imagine this woman's going to be picked up by other people
then, right? This story should get validated outside of the New
York Post. Wait, you said this is the
Hold on. Is this person actually a streamer? They're followed
by Flesh Simulator. What? My statement regarding Graham Platner.
I was very briefly I very briefly was talking to and then consequently
seeing Grand Platner from about February 2021 to mid July 2021
when it was revealed to me that he was cheating on his fiance
at the time. He knew about the tattoo. Yeah, Lau. Yep. Seeing
stuff his stuff on social media. You were right. He's kind of
hot. Too bad he's a douche. Yeah. Small makes weird noises. Nazi
tattoo was around on his fiance. Good riddens. All fixable except
cheater. I don't know man. I think that's a lot. There's a lot
of that that isn't fixable. No way. He's got a decent platform.
Better not take a peek at the Nazi tattoo in his chest.
How about the tattoo? Call Graham last night because no one no
one that I know has jumper cables and the boys are out of town
and I ran my battery out listening to music and smoking in my
car. Okay, hold on. And then they did a full statement on Grand
Platner as well. No dates on the incriminating text. Well, this
was this one was September
I assume, of 2025 since that's the last September that happened,
right? That does put it a little earlier than some of the other
stuff though, so we'll have to see. Hey, they did a whole big
statement here. All right, the person who's a leftist, I immediately
looked at him and asked, "Is that a toteenoff?" And he told me
a whole he will hold his weight forever bravado sobb story about
how it was, but he decided to keep it as a reminder that the
United States was the evil bad guy overseas. She recounted, I
don't I'm sorry.
I don't necessarily believe
this this story right here, but we'll see. Okay, we'll we'll
have to keep reading. That's so weird that he was dating somebody
who's like popular on Twitter, though.
Odd. Not that it's impossible, just odd. Does include a screenshot
image of Platner on a boat showing off oysters dated June 15th,
2021 in Bar Harbor, Maine, not far from his hometown. Platner
told the woman someone in his military leadership suggested the
whole crew get the skull and crossbones tattoo because he was
a military history buff. The woman said she said she met Platner
on Tinder and texted with him months before dating him in 2021
when she moved to Maine for work. Okay. It seems like he was
tailored he tailored his answer to me knowing my politics since
the one that's one of the reasons we matched on Tinder in the
first place. She reflected the pair started talking in February
2021 and dated until mid July 2021. She said the post confirmed
that the woman she had multiple confirmed that the woman had
multiple posts on social media alluding to a diance with Graham
during that period of time. Late octo last October she posted
that Graham Platner is a piece of but he's not but not because
he's a communist. She alleges that their romance together ended
when she found out from mutuals that Platner was engaged to another
woman around that time. Multiple sources confirm Platner had
a previous fiance before oh a previous fiance. I see. Before
getting married to Amy Gertner in 2023, whom he allegedly cheated
on via sexing in a bombshell story that broke last month.
Graham repeatedly said he picked a skull and crossbones tattoo
off a wall in Croatia to commemorate surviving Romani with his
friends who were killed there. A spokesperson from the Platiner
campaign told the Post. Graham has since covered up the tattoo
and answered countless questions about it. Unlike Susan Collins,
who refuses to take questions on her disastrous vote to confirm
Brett Kavanaaugh got rural hospital blah blah blah blah blah.
Is there anything else about this woman in here? Are they doing
the whole story, the whole timeline? I'm just looking to see
if we got anything else from this woman. No. Okay, that's it
from this woman. Let's read her statement real quick and then
we'll get into some of the drama stuff. All right.
In the winter of 2020/201,
as CO restrictions lessened, I decided I was going to work in
Maine for the summer. Working seasonal jobs since 18, I quickly
secured a job working housekeeping for a glamping resort in Maine
outside of Aadia National Park. There was just one problem. I
had never been to Maine. I'd never been to the Northeast or farther
than Maryland.
Having had success making a couple of friends during the stricter
CO protocols of 2020 using Tinder, I gave it a try. Dude, why
can't women just admit they want to hook up when they go somewhere?
I Dude, what what is this? What the is this? What is this weird
story?
What's this weird ass story, man? I actually made a lot of friends
on Tinder in 2020. So, I when I went to a new place, I got on
Tinder cuz I wanted to make friends. No, you didn't.
What? That's insane. That's an insane thing. You just said that
you just said an insane thing. I The one thing I need is guy
friends who want to me
said no woman ever. Ever.
Okay. Anyway, we keep going.
I figured it would function as a way to meet people in the area
and learn more about it ahead of moving. That's when I matched
with Graham.
had things like support IWW and my specific political inclinations
listed in my profile intentionally to steer clear of people I
couldn't see myself agreeing with and he gravitated towards this
things started out friendly enough but then quickly became nature
but I thought he was hot and he was a leftist and I was 27 and
freshly out of an incredibly tumultuous polit time politically
and a global health crisis I'm not sure exactly when we matched
because Tinder will not let me look that far back but I know
it was at least early March when I finally arrived in Maine for
my job in mid April I was excited to meet in person and as we
had been talking, exchanging photos, etc. since we had matched,
he told me that he was actually going or actually in DC for a
wedding that week, the week I arrived and said we'd make plans
once he returned. We'll revisit this later. He was with his fiance
probably. We went on dates in public out in the open. I went
to his house when we finally got intimate. I was lying my head
on his chest like a well-informed leftist I am. But the swooning
woman I was, I asked him point blank. Uh, oh my god, crazy question,
but is that a toten cough tattooed on your chest? Huh? No worries.
If not, lol. I remember this plain as day. He sighed and put
a hand to his forehead and pushed his hair back and said, "Yeah."
He explained that he didn't know what it was when he was younger,
but his leader or whatever military variety of whatever military
variety was big into World War II history and suggested him and
his team all get it. My obvious response was, "Wow. Oh my god."
That like, "Oh my god." So, so crazy. Lol. Why didn't you get
a removed? He provided what at the time was a pretty convincing
explanation that when he finally returned from the war and then
private contracting and had settled into leftist ideology, he
kept it as a reminder that the United States and by extension
himself were THE BAD GUYS. OH,
WAIT. That makes Wait, that's not what the New York Post led
me to believe. Oh, that that actually makes a way that's a huge
difference, right? Like the way the New York Post lays it out,
it's like he's saying the the US were the bad guys because they
got rid of the Nazis. But what he's saying is I operated as like
a Nazi soldier. That's how I see my service in some ways. Like
I was the bad guy. That's like way way way way
different. A blood brand of sorts that he would that would serve
as a constant reminder of his growth and change, but a mark he
would always carry. Now that's one hell of a way to clean up.
Stuck the landing. He shoots. He scores. A sob story of monumental
proportions that only further solidifies solidified my perception
of his ideology. But surprisingly enough, not the one he gave
to the people of Maine or the citizens watching at home because
if he said that, he would lose. You cannot be you cannot call
the US military the Nazi regime of the world. That would Yeah,
that would obviously be disastrous for his campaign. Is this
person unaware of that? This actually No, no, no. This actually
might help him.
Like this this could easily help him,
that he can go, "No, no, I don't feel that way." But realistically,
this helps with like some lefty types.
Like, not that you would ever want this story to come out because
it does seem like the the lying thing again. But this is why
I decided to speak about this. I made jokes with friends, played
it off like it wasn't a big deal, and tried to just duck my head
down and pretend it didn't happen. But it did. If Graham Platner
told the American public on Al Gore's internet the same story
he told me, even if it was a lie crafted and tailored to my perception
of him, he would have proven his platform further still, and
there would be nothing for me to say. But the problem is he didn't.
He got on microphones and stages and gathering halls and told
people that at his big age of 41, he was just finding out about
this now. We stopped talking shortly after that because a friend
relayed to me that while she was at his house having some of
our mutual friends look at his car, her car, he was talking about
a woman he had blown it with, saying she was the love of his
life. I was naively and probably a little too stareyed for my
own good, or I was naive and probably a little too stareyed for
my own good. But as a person who had been on only a handful of
dates with him and around a bit, I was smart enough to know he
wasn't talking about me. I took the hint. It wasn't until a month
later in August upon having a conversation with a mutual friend
and it being revealed to me that I had been seeing Graham, I
found I had been seeing Graham when maybe she means we when she
was seeing Graham. I found out that he had been engaged the entire
time we were talking and exchanging photos and videos. I can't
say for certain if he was still engaged when we were seeing each
other in person, just that this mutual friend told me he was
engaged to a woman named Jen
and that she had walked in on him having sex with another person
at a wedding they were in at in DC. Oh,
Graham Graham's starting to come off like a sex addict now. Okay,
this is rough. This is rough. I mean, this isn't going to hurt
him politically. I'm sorry. These kinds of stories don't hurt
you politically. I wish they did. I wish this kind of character
hurt you in a political sense, but it straight up
unfortunately. You know what I mean?
I I wish people cared about this kind of character flaw, that
you're like a liar, that you will betray the people closest to
you, but they just don't.
I don't know what it is.
That mutual friend also advised that he was trying to repair
things with this woman and asked me if I was going to seek her
out to tell her.
The sentiment there was very similar to what I've been feeling
since the announcement of his campaign. I was a stranger in a
strange land. I wouldn't be there for very long. We were no longer
involved and I wasn't exactly keen on inviting any additional
bad blood. Small towns, you know. I didn't feel the need to say
anything publicly because it had nothing to do with me. It was
another long in a long line of admittedly embarrassing admittedly
embarrassing experiences with men and a funny self-deprecating
joke in a few group chats. That was until he lied. And I thought
about coming forward then, too. But to do so would be to invite
the kind of vitrial that I am seeing now. I no longer live in
Maine. I have my lone life and I have my own stressors closer
to home.
At the time, I didn't feel the need to add to the pile. However,
after these last revelations, it seems that my story was one
of the most recent. The way these women have been brushed off,
scrutinized over their political leanings, accused of being paid
agitators, and dragged through the mud was well, there's literally
only one woman who is accused of that, and she is literally a
paid agitator, so to speak. But okay, I I'd have no problem with
this woman coming out or whatever and saying all this happens,
right? Or all this happened, but it's just like it's like she's
quite uninformed of the current situation
is all it just feels weird. Anyway,
drag through the mod was not only uncalled for, but also stands
in direct opposition to everything that Graham Platner seems
to espouse. He did real
Wait, what did he do? What What should he do? I I'm so this feels
weird. Like
there's something weird going on with this. Like I'm fine with
this story coming out or or this person publishing their story
on Twitter.
It just seems odd to me that
I I don't know what he did in this case in terms of going after
Lindsay. Anyway, he did real harm. Although my time in his orbit
was short, he still robbed me of my agency in a place I have
never been before and left me open to the possibility of social
ridicule. I'd come to Maine knowing nothing and no one except
for him with the expectation of spending time with someone romantically.
And what I got was disappointment, an embarrassing story, a never
returned pie dish, and a deep sense of grief and regret. Compared
to some of the other women who have come forward, that is a drop
in the bucket.
I'm no I'm under no illusion that I, user, 420 mercy 69 on X,
the Everything app, FKA, formerly known as Twitter, am going
to destroy his campaign. But I'm not and I'm not trying to. But
I am stepping forward as a person who experienced lying and manipulation
by his hand to lend my voice to what is a growing number of women
who have been wronged by this man in one way or another, regardless
of their political leanings. People that I've admired are brushing
this off, discounting women's experiences, attacking other journalists,
or allowing people in their comment sections to do so. Especially
with regards to do domestic violence. It is hideous.
I really I really don't Oh man, this person I wish I could have
like a conversation with this person to be honest with you. He's
talking about Kyle. I like I said, Kyle's going way too hard
on this, right? Like he's I wouldn't speak that way personally
cuz it just feels like
Yeah. I don't know. My thoughts on that woman were like, if this
is all true, it's it's sad the way it's all come out. Keep reading.
Why do I care? Why even come forward at all? What is the point?
The point is that regardless of whether or not I reside a maid,
a man that I know to be a liar, a cheater, and a manipulator
in my own firsthand experience is petitioning to become a member
of the legislative body that will dictate the way this country
is run. It's not a question of whether or not Susan Collins is
monumentally better or monumentally worse. It has nothing to
do with Susan Collins. It has everything to do with the fact
that if we want a better Democratic party, we need to elect better
Democrats.
Uh there aren't better Democrats, unfortunately. I wish there
were better Democrats. I wish.
Yeah, this is why, by the way, this just 10xes
my appreciation for Abdul say and the idea that he needs to be
like held up and protected at all costs. You know what I mean?
That like that guy is actually like the real deal. And I always
knew Graham Platiner was going to have these wars. And especially
once I heard about the this and stuff, I was like, "Oh yeah,
this guy's like probably a lying narcissist who doesn't really
care about people."
Like I could tell I could tell that he wasn't he was almost certainly
not a good person. I like the rhetoric. I like the campaign or
I like the platform, but lying narcissist in general, which is
probably not that far off. Like I don't think he's that far off
spiritually from Gavin Newsome or something. You know what I
mean? Like these people are just psychos. Like actual psychopaths
who don't care about other people. And
it's like, okay, well there's something to it that that those
are the people who gravitate towards politics, I guess.
Oh well, here's her opinion on Gavin Newsome, which is actually
pretty in line with what I was thinking. Shut the absolute goddamn
up. Gavin Newsome is evil. That is why it's not that hard. We
are done capitulating to terrorists that refuse to actually do
anything to make this country to make things better for the country.
I do I don't give a [__] about Hassan [__]
Gavin Newsome is so rotten he'd squatchch if he squeezed him.
Yeah. Yeah, I think so. I think so. I think so. Okay, dude. That's
uh that's kind of crazy.
We're back to this. So, we need to vote for better Democrats.
It does not stop there. There will be more information that comes
out. There will be more people affected by the harm he has caused
or allowed to be caused. I am just one of many people fought
and died for my right to vote. And it is my it is a responsibility
I personally do not take lightly. I refuse to surrender that
small blessing I am allowed to bestow in hopes of stalwart leadership
to someone I don't think will be a stalwart leader. If I Yeah,
you you literally don't have a vote here, but okay. [clears throat]
If I were a main voter, seeing the things I'm seeing, I wouldn't
have voted for him. Personal experience notwithstanding because
I do not trust him. Why, after all that that has come out, would
I? Because he won the nomination and he's not Susan Collins.
That's literally all that's literally all you actually need to
know. Yeah, this is just not intelligent.
But this person's like a hardcore lefty. No hardcore lefty is
intelligent. Sorry. all the all the Twitter lefties. This is
like exactly the kind of Twitter lefty that can't like this is
unironically the person Hutch talks about. And I have no problem
with her coming out with this story. I I suspect this is baked
into the candidate. It's like not going to make a difference.
I'm just telling you that when Hutch talks about Twitter lefties
who can't get anything done because they will never like they
can never make any pragmatic choice, that's this person. Just
saying.
But it's her right not to make the pragmatic choice. I'm not
I'm not going to on her for that.
She doesn't want to do that. That's all good. Jeez. Okay,
one last paragraph.
In Dune, Frank Herbert wrote, "Power attracts the corruptible.
People sus suspect all who seek it. We should grant power only
over our affairs, only to those who are reluctant to hold it,
and then only under conditions that increase that reluctance."
I personally find it highly suspect that after all that has happened,
this one lone man is being lauded as a key to salvation while
still reaching ever forward towards a position of power very
few of us will ever understand.
If we are going to build progress, if we are going to build a
platform that cares for the most vulnerable of us, we are going
to need a much better hammer. Yeah, this is one of those cases
I
like it's just and the weird thing is
is like I have no problem with her saying I don't trust this
guy.
I would just I would wonder like it is ultimately a lesser evil
thing and
you waited until all of this came out to talk about it. I don't
know. It It feels odd. It just feels kind of odd and I Oh man.
Yeah. It just feels odd. It just doesn't make sense to me. But
it's okay. It's all right. Okay. We need to
start moving forward. I think we're getting into this Ethan Klein
stuff pretty quick here. Point in his favor is that people apparently
tried to recruit him to run in 2020. Oh, I'm a main reporter
who went to high school with Graham Platner. Here's what explains
his success. Okay. Well, this is a lot of stuff, but apparently
he got recruited to run in 2020 as well and didn't want to. So,
cool.
Important tweets.
Why is this tweet important? I'm never going to stop sing for
Hassan [__] He's simply too hot.
Wow. Cool.
It's funny to me that this story like only sticks. You could
see the angle they want to run with that he's like anti-Semitic,
that he's a Nazi. And this story has like teeth to it, but not
on these grounds.
It's just very funny that that's the angle they feel like they
have to go at. They can't not go at that angle. That is the most
important angle all the time, right? Like there's a real actual
bad person there that they could attack, but they can't because
they don't care, right?
They don't care. They they literally only care about one
Near post writers and editors only care about one thing and it's
disgusting.
The Holy Land.